Угу...
Ну-ка, ну-ка, ну-ка...
[зітхає]
Вау!
Море...
Клас!
Вау.
Вууух!
Клас!
Це ж... Це Кача.
Це берег біля Севастополя неподалік.
Ах, ага. Чуфут-Кале, так.
Клас!
Це взагалі було перше місце,
куди я потрапив після того, як у 1989 році прилетів.
І саме цією стежкою ми
піднімалися біля Успенського монастиря.
Коли дивишся вниз, то бачиш там будівлю.
А на цьому місці багато-багато років тому,
у XVI столітті, був заснований найстаріший ВНЗ у Східній Європі.
Цей заклад мав назву Зинджирли-медресе.
Це в перекладі «університет ланцюга».
Ага, старе кладовище, так...
Тут — на Чуфут-кале, а там — Успенський монастир.
Тут ми збирали фундук.
Ану-ка... Вау! Ууу!
[з захопленням зітхає]
Клас! Ось вона, доріжка.
О, тут зробили поручні! Раніше не було.
І так ми піднімалися в той час, у 1989 році ще,
той східний вхід був відчинений,
і там навіть нікого не було.
Так, а це західні... Це західні ворота.
Ууу, вау! [втішено сміється]
Ого! [з величезним захопленням у голосі]
Трохи лячно, я вам скажу!
Ууу! [захоплено]
Так, а це що?
Капсіхор!
Це батьківщина моєї мами.
Зараз воно [називається] Морське.
Як круто, уууух ти ж!
[з величезним захопленням у голосі]
[вражено зітхає]
Оце так! Вау!
Так, а там праворуч, якщо я не помиляюся,
гора Алчак чи [мис] Меганом?
Ні.
Якщо це Капсіхор, там Судак...
Бахчисарай.
Це Хан-Джамі [Велика ханська мечеть],
це центральний вхід.
Розарій... Боже, як тепло!
Це, можливо, найперше місце,
до якого мене привезли мої брати,
коли я переїхав до Криму.
11 липня 1989 року я прилетів [до Криму]
через 11 днів після закінчення середньої
[загальноосвітньої] школи в Узбекистані.
Це було надзвичайне враження.
Потім стільки разів я був у тому палаці,
приводив друзів туди,
знімав всередині палацу майже скрізь.
І деякі епізоди з деяких моїх стрічок, і сам знімався.
Там ми грали мою виставу «Бахчисарайський фонтан».
Там прямо всередині цього палацу.
Так багато пов'язано з ним.
Так...
Реконструкція...
Доброго дня!
Угу.
Це так виглядає зараз?
А що ж вони там роблять?
Йой... [засмучено зітхає]
Сім років [тут не був].
Власне, це був день...
Я пам'ятаю, коли я вперше приїхав в уже такому віці,
у 1989 році, після школи.
І, власне, Ханський палац в один день,
потім — Успенський монастир.
Його взагалі там не було, він був такий занедбаний.
А потім ми пішки піднялися на Чуфут-Кале.
І там, власне, на Чуфут-Кале, якщо ви пам'ятаєте,
там, коли йдеш центральною вулицею,
а праворуч є будинок, в якому мешкав
Агатангел Кримський — легендарний перекладач.
У мене було відчуття, що я знаю точно, що там за рогом.
Так зване дежавю.
Так і сталося.
І це було таке перше враження,
ніби ти дійсно пов'язаний з цією землею,
тому що ти ніколи там [раніше] не був, на Чуфут-Кале,
а знаєш точно, що там за рогом.
І там був той колодязь,
в якому наповнюється вода
після того, як дощ іде.
Скільки разів ми грали тут?
Прямо на цьому місці.
На майданчику.
У Бахчисараї.
Тут і гімн співали, тут і зйомки відбувалися, скільки разів...
Таке відчуття, що я його...
Знав повністю весь.
Це якесь НЛО!
Так треба мабуть, не знаю.
Якось дико виглядає, ніби стадіон.
Хух! [гучно зітхає]
Надзвичайне враження.
Клас.
Дякую.
[коротко зітхає]
Це круто.
І боляче,
і надзвичайно.
Таке відчуття, ніби ти уві сні.
Дивишся все те, що сім років тобі сниться.
Клас.
Респект і уважуха.
[сумно всміхається]